le verdict est tombé nicolas sarkozy a
été déclarée coupable de corruption et
de trafic d'influencé dans l' affaire
dite des écoutes qui avait éclaté en
2014 deux ans après son départ de
l'elysée
l'ex président a écopé de trois ans de
prison dont un an fin qui pourraient
être aménagés l annonce de cette
condamnation nicolas sarkozy a
rapidement quitté la salle sans dire un
mot à la presse qui était à présente
herzog asie verts sont restés
s'entretenir un moment avec leurs
avocats
un peu secoué du jugement cette
condamnation à la prison ferme et est
une première sous la vème république
c'était un procès est très important
pour un nicolas sarkozy puisqu'il s'agit
du premier jugement dans la liste des
affaires judiciaires qui le concernent
depuis la fin de son mandat à l'elysée
selon la juge christine mais nicolas
sarkozy s'est servi de son statut de ses
relations politiques et diplomatiques
pour gratifier un magistrat y avoir des
informations confidentielles notamment
sur l'en quête des présumés versements
illégaux que nicolas sarkozy aurait reçu
de la part de la milliardaire liliane
bettencourt
pour l'accusation certaines
conversations prouve bien qu'il y a eu
un pacte entre elle et trois hommes un
pacte de corruption ce sont ses mots
l'avocat thierry herzog et l'ancien haut
magistrat gilbert azibert était assise
aux côtés de l'ancien chef de l'état ils
ont également été condamnés à trois ans
prison dont un an ferme avec
l'interdiction d'exercer la profession
d'avocat pendant cinq ans pour être
thierry herzog qui résonne qui a lui
fait appel de cette décision
mais le feuilleton judiciaire n'est pas
terminée pour nicolas sarkozy
l'icône des républicains qui n'a jamais
écarté un possible retour à la vie
politique il va devoir comparaître à
nouveau devant la justice dès le 17 mars
dans la sphère bygmalion pour des
soupçons de financement illégal